Hello Freak bitches.
If it wasn't for Thanksgiving,
would anybody give a fuck about Turkey
country?
Hold Hunter?
No.
Nobody likes to eat Turkey.
I mean,
it's good,
but it's not the best.
Not cheap grain is better than Turkey.
Can we agree?
Yeah.
There's no Kentucky Fried Turkey.
There's no Turkey stores now.
Chicken stores ever.
There's Popeye's chicken,
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
Bernays,
bernays Turkey Bacon for breakfast.
Is is completely an invention
of this advertising guy?
Yeah.
He was hired by the company.
I forget the name of the company,
but they're still around in some form
that hired him to sell more pork.
And so he came up with this
idea like bacon and eggs.
What's for breakfast?
You got to like integrate it
into the cultural traditions.
Wow.
And ever since then it's been
considered breakfast meat and boom.
Meanwhile it's awesome.
So congratulations.
So he was also behind the fluoridation
of the water supply hired by Alcoa
because they had all this,
all this.
I'm a byproduct of making aluminum,
which is this fluoride.
And they wanted to like,
what are we going to
do with all this stuff?
You know,
we gotta find a way to sell it.
Who could we sell it to?
And he figured out like,
Oh,
we can,
you know,
it's good for dental.
It'll save everyone and get
the government to buy it.
It's so funny.
We accept that man because like if someone
comes over to your house and you're
like,
and you want some water,
and they're like,
yeah.
And you're like,
do you want me to add some fluoride to it?
I'd be like,
fuck yeah,
it is a chemical that kills you.
So yeah.
Could you put fluoride
in your ad can kill you.
It doesn't take a whole lot.
Like how much kills you?
Like a couple of teaspoons full.
I don't know.
I have no die with white teeth.
But is that real?
What's going on with
dental hygiene versus.
I mean,
is it Florida in the water that makes a
difference or being conscious of dental
hygiene,
dental hygiene.
It's made the difference
in tooth decay and people.
Well,
I mean talking to take,
you know,
you talking to me,
I'm always going to take
it back to foragers.
Foragers have amazing teeth.
Roots and shit though.
Well,
some sand in a Weston Smith.
What is this?
We put in this.
Oh,
this is bernays.
Said that get the Bacon for breakfast and
he is also responsible for fluoride in
the water
for Dixie Cup.
Jamie is just like Dixie Cup show
and then I'm not full of Shit.
I love it.
Jamie.
Thinking that they were
drinking out of unsafe.
What?
Look at this,
his campaign for Dixie Cups.
Scared people into thinking that
glasses they were drinking out of where?
Unsanitary and can be
replaced by disposable cups.
Wow.
Did you read this before?
You put it up.
That's insane.
And it was the beach nut
packing company that's hired.
This guy was amazing,
but the bake and he got it right.
Oh he got.
He got everything right.
Dead on with the Bacon.
Bacon.
He also was behind the
Virginia slims thing.
Oh,
how can we use feminism to
get women to buy cigarettes?
It's a feminist cigarette.
Come a long way,
baby.
I bet that guy got laid like crazy.
I bet he was just a fucking maestro.
And he was Freud's nephew.
Oh my goodness.
So he had the benefit of psychological
examination under his uncle.
He's proud of himself like he doesn't.
He just died like 10 years ago.
He's like,
yeah,
I did all this shit,
but he's happy.
His success ratio was amazing,
right?
Oh,
he hit every one out of the park.
I've said there's more,
and I really mean this.
There is more intellectual debate in
one hour of twitter than there is a four
years of college.
I mean there's far more conflict of ideas
on social media now than there isn't a
college classroom because college
classrooms are dominated and have been for
decades by left liberals.
That's the discourse
that goes on in there.
You don't hear conservative ideas,
you don't hear libertarian ideas,
you don't even hear some
radical left wing ideas.
It's this very narrow discourse that is
pretty much only allowed in the college
classroom and that's to me the most.
The biggest problem with
the modern university,
there is no diversity of ideas.
Everybody's obsessed
with diversity of color,
skin color,
but no one cares about a diversity.
Diversity of ideas about real debate.
I want in my university to have
a real debate about big ideas.
I want the best minds from conservatism
and liberalism and socialism and
libertarianism to have it out to.
Let's talk about the big ideas and
let's go for it and have the best people
argue the points on their
merits against each other.
Why is it that there's such a narrow
path of ideas that exist right now in
college is why is it just
this tenure track tenure?
Yeah.
I mean,
so what happened was conservatives
basically dominated colleges until the 19
sixties and then the 19 sixties generation
of radicals had nowhere to go when
they went into their
twenties and thirties,
so they decided to move into the academy,
so they all got phds and they became
professors and they've dominated ever
since.
There's also the system
of tenure in universities,
which is supposed to
protect academic freedom,
and what it actually does is it
enforces intellectual conformity,
right?
Because you have a lifetime appointment
and you and you control hiring,
right?
The faculty controls hiring.
Who?
Who are you going to hire?
You're going to hire
somebody who agrees with you.
Who says what you think should be said?
So that's the problem with tenure,
right?
It sort of protects academic freedom,
but mostly it enforces
intellectual conformity.
That's disturbing.
It's disturbing because
you see it's a priesthood.
Yeah.
In a way.
Right?
Right.
You're,
you're a priest for life.
And who are you going to
recruit into the priesthood.
A true
believer.
That's what goes on in universities.
You know why they didn't go to that?
Why?
Why is it not go that way?
Because I would have gone off on
him that he would have beat up Jack,
right?
Luke and the one that would
be in that room that night.
I know how to motivate
Cubans or with religion,
that radicals you would do.
You would just start talking about God,
I just told them about.
Oh,
goon got metal,
God of Cuba,
and he looked at,
wait a minute,
hold on a to go.
And he used the one that he.
The metal worker.
He's the fucking built.
And when you go on Youtube,
look,
throat ghoulies is always a big yield.
Black Guy lives in the
jungle and he only comes out.
The only comes out when there's a problem,
so if I would've seen
Yoel Romero that day,
I would have said Google
and I would have got a gun.
Like God love going,
Shit Dog.
I started doing that to end this and
silver when I first met him and I remember
one day in the hallway he
couldn't take his eyes off of me.
People talking to him.
They kept looking back,
fuck the sand because
it's big in Brasilia,
Brasilia Brazilian.
So I would've started saying,
oh Whoa,
oh yeah.
Or,
and then I would have started
saying who my mother is whole lot.
You see my periodic golden eat that leg
after I bought good to look.
That's the dude.
That's your marrow.
Look it up.
You know all black muscular Cuban
dudes that looked like that.
You fire them up,
tell them they're old and they go,
shit,
I'll get you fired up at all before.
This is huge in Cuba.
It was this guy,
this guy right here,
he.
So there's like a series
of black porn films.
These guys shirtless,
six pack covered in oil.
This is the price of the jungle.
And he is in charge of machinery when you,
when machinery goes
bad and shit like that,
you have to pray to him.
He has all the weapons of metal.
He just shows up in metal and stuff.
He has a metal,
acts metal,
fucking everything that.
So that's what I would have busted
him with that I would've just.
I would've gotten through
his head without going.
I hate that.
That takes over Jesus and Cuba.
That's what you were brought up on.
You heard that grown up.
So even if you converted
to Christianity later on,
that will still get under your skin,
like your cage and shit profile
to stop saying that shit.
Everybody I there,
right?
John Mccarthy?
It would have been an episode of curly
and the little rascals when they fund
that little rascal three stooges,
they want to currently
wrestle for a benefit.
But the problem was whenever
curly smelled wild license,
she went fucking nuts.
So he's on the bottom of the pile.
The guys beating them and all of a sudden
what comes over and makes them sniff
the fucking thing
currently pushes him off.
What is it called?
Wild Heisei,
wild hyacinth like some
fucking something you,
you know,
this is like in the forties it was made
and all of a sudden you flashback and
you just see curly,
everybody,
people coming up and then
he gets a little bit belt.
At least starts clocking people with
the bell from the wild licensed and they
flip over the curly hitting
people with the Bow Austin,
they flip over to the middle of the ring
and they're all piled on top of each
other though 18 people with that fucking.
That's what I would have done
through the yellow metal that day.
He would've gotten until the Orleans Bang.
Your head was fucking.
What's his name?
Goldberg.